hi I'm Claudia valadares from bangkok on
acharya velasco in Venezuela thank you
very much for the question the question
is what what keeps me motivated and I
really I I'm always inspired for my work
in terms of alleviating poverty in my
country I think that's the passion to
work for the poor people and try to
improve their lives through microfinance
I think this is a wonderful opportunity
for developing an initiative that has
changing the lives of poor people
accessing credit and provided financial
inclusion and I invite all the people
who look in this to find and look for
the passion in their hearts in order to
to make social changes that improve the
world thank you